[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
from the nation's capital the American
Enterprise Institute for Public Policy
Research present public policy for a
series of programs featuring the
nation's top authorities presenting
their differing views on the vital
issues which confront us the topic
freedom of the press the First Amendment
protections should reporters be forced
by the courts to reveal confidential
sources of information to what extent
should the First Amendment protect the
press from libel suits by private
citizens now here is Peter haggis in
this Bicentennial era as we re-examine
some of the great principles on which
this country is based freedom of the
press stands out as a cornerstone of our
democracy from time to time that word
freedom has to be spelled out in detail
if the First Amendment of the
Constitution is to have some specific
meaning is the press free for example to
print any item even if it might damage
the individual rights of a certain
person is the press free not to print
certain items because a government
agency says it might be a threat to
national security
and who decides these matters the
newspaper the government a court should
a reporter be privileged protected by a
legal shield against being forced to
reveal his news sources does the public
have an absolute right to know from the
National Press Club in Washington
welcome to another roundtable discussion
presented by the American Enterprise
Institute a nonprofit nonpartisan
research and education organization
today's guests are well versed in the
topic freedom of the press the First
Amendment protections members of our
panel are Charles sive associate editor
of The Washington Post mr. Steve has
been a reporter or editor for The
Associated Press Canet News surface and
the Washington star Floyd Abrams a
partner in a New York law firm which
specializes in communications law he has
filed many briefs in first amendment
court cases Antonin Scalia an assistant
US Attorney General involved in press
free
cases mr. Scalia served as general
counsel in the White House Office of
telecommunications and as chairman of
the administrative conference Edward
Epstein director of a research project
on news agencies sponsored by the 20th
century fund he's author of the book
news from nowhere Jack Nelson is
Washington bureau chief of the Los
Angeles Times he's a Pulitzer Prize
winner for his investigative reporting
while serving as a reporter for the
Atlanta Constitution moderating our
discussion is William Ruckelshaus mr.
Ruckelshaus served as deputy US Attorney
General and as head of the Civil
Division of the Justice Department he
also headed the FBI and the
Environmental Protection Agency
mr. Rocco's house practices law in
Washington DC now our moderator mr.
Rocco saps
Thank You mr. hackus the First Amendment
to the United States Constitution states
Congress shall make no law abridging
freedom of the press who are our history
the meaning of those words and the
nature of the freedom it protects have
caused controversy tonight we are going
to discuss with our distinguished panel
and later the audience three current
controversies whose common theme
involves the tension between the First
Amendment and the government's exercise
of power through the judicial system
news man's privilege should a reporter
under any circumstances be forced by the
courts to reveal their confidential
sources of information the Supreme Court
in 1972 in the case of Branzburg against
Hayes said under certain circumstances a
newsman could be forced to testify
before a grand jury and forced to
disclose the identity of their
confidential news sources since that
time and really before several so-called
shield laws have been introduced in
Congress and in the States to protect
the confidentiality of a news man's
source from judicial interference libel
what extent those are should the First
Amendment to the United
States Constitution protect the press
from rival actions by private citizens
claiming they were wrong
is there or should there be a difference
between the protection provided a
private citizen and the public figure
lastly to what extent should the court
prohibit the publication of classified
material starting with a Pentagon Papers
case and continuing with the current
sensational revelations about our
intelligence-gathering agency are there
any limits in the name of national
security to what may be published in no
particular order let's start with news
man's privilege mr. Nelson let me ask
you should the Congress of the United
States pass a shield law absolutely
protecting the rights of a newsman not
to reveal is confidential news sources
anywhere in the country well I think
Congress shouldn't pass such a law and I
think it should be an absolute law and
unqualified law I would be opposed any
sort of law that had qualifications and
that might hurt them such a bill to
amendment in the future and I've
actually just saved by way of background
that the team will remember a number of
a group call the reporters committee for
freedom of the press which is formed
after Eric Halliwell was subpoenaed and
the first case where the Justice
Department began to subpoena reporters
during the Nixon administration this
committee formed of working reporters
mostly in Washington saw that there was
a necessity to protect reporters and
their confidential sources in cases
particularly where an investigation of
governance concerns and this and the
reporters committee has been in favor
from the outset of an unqualified law
now I think for example that if the
Nixon administration for example had
been able to subpoena wouldn't Bernstein
of the post other reporters and learn
confidential sources you would have
never
Watergate uncovered and and there are
many other stories that you can look at
that never come out had reporters been
subpoenaed and had they been forth to
the world confidential solicitor mr.
Scalia you're from the Department of
Justice you have a contrary view to that
or you support me no I I think miss mr.
Nelson you is the most the most rational
next to what I think is the correct one
and that is that there should not be
movements British law there the reason I
say it's the the most logical next to
that is that there are many who think
well we should have a newsman as
privileged law but it should be
qualified and and that I think is the
worst of both worlds the problem is if
you have one that's unqualified it you
just can't live with it and if you have
one that's qualified it just doesn't
work so I think the the best state of
the law is the one that we now have in
which you cannot get a newsman to
testify in court all the time there are
judicial protections against powers me
but on the other hand there is no
instance in which a newsman can go in
and say categorically the law gives me
an absolute privilege not to not to
appear it really doesn't help the
discussion to put the whole thing in the
context of the Nixon administration
subpoena a newsman it normally isn't the
Nixon administration it's normally a
court in a criminal case and as often as
not they are subpoenaing the newsman not
on behalf of the government but on
behalf of the defendant I would agree
with you that you shouldn't necessarily
put in just in the context of the makin
administration but you've got to realize
that the subpoenaing of reporters did
not begin though about a Justice
Department Information Administration
well I don't like I doubt very much
whether that's true I don't know the
fact that all the facts on how many
newsmen subpoenas there have ever been
in the history of American jurisprudence
but I find it difficult to imagine that
that a newsman has net had never been
subpoenaed on behalf of either the
government or the defense in any in any
criminal trial prior to Nixon at least I
just come to look into it and there was
certainly our impression on reading
every case we could find that prior to
the Nixon administration that had been
very very few cases
very very few subpoenas issuing
certainly out of the Department of
Justice there there was a new and to the
press and I think the public disastrous
flow of subpoenas pouring out of the
Department of Justice in the early days
of the Nixon administration that has
stopped certainly to a major extent we
do have I'd like to add a qualified
privilege now in there as a matter of
law because of the cases that that have
developed in the new nelson that that
absolute privilege would be a better
idea but I don't think really we should
let pass the idea that a qualified
privilege doesn't do any good we do have
one now case after case is coming down
and forth after court around the country
which is establishing that in situations
in which there are alternative sources
for example to get information you can't
go to the newsmen first idea very much
you can't go to the news net first the
Justice Department guidelines for
subpoena movement provided exactly that
and I have no quarrel with that if
you're talking about a qualified
privilege that is judicially created and
administered or one that is
administratively created or administered
but I thought we were talking about
legislation that would establish a
qualified privilege in the sense that
you don't a judge it on a case by case
basis but you have some flat rule that
will be applied in a certain category of
cases I don't think that achieves what
the main purpose of the news man's
privilege law is intended to achieve and
that is to open up confidential sources
and and prevent these so-called chilling
effect upon confidential sources because
mr. chief has a remark I just ordered if
this was a realistic discussion is there
any possibility at all of getting an
absolute privilege law out of Congress
no I doubt to me the period and once you
know one time there seemed to be a part
well once you concede that you can't
wonder rather stay with the First
Amendment and get into a word and I
think limited you said you wouldn't do
that I said I would so I have no quarrel
with the fact that
newse method for two reason what one is
that the freedom of the press is a
particularly important freedom under our
Constitution and it deserves some it has
some special constitutional protection
and the second one is that news men are
particularly subject to the harassment
by thought by subpoenas because they're
in the business of finding out
investigating facts police departments
could come to rely upon them to do their
jobs for both of those reasons I think
it makes sense to Accord them some
special protection through the courts
and through the administrators such as
the Justice Department not subpoena
newsmen willy nilly which we don't do
but beyond that I don't think any more
is needed or is indeed desirable
teresting what's your view on well I
don't really think that the clarify the
issue and to try and pretend that there
has been freedom of the press up to the
Nixon administration and somehow the
Nixon administration violated this
freedom of press by subpoenaing
reporters is historically accurate I
think you had complete censorship in
World War two and the Korean War when
newspapers and magazines were told what
to publish under covers that stories to
publish and they were threatened editors
were threatened by being drafted in the
army unless they went along you had the
McCarthy period stretching into the
early 50s when newsmen certainly didn't
have any sort of freedom to report what
they wanted to and while you might say
that you could find very few cases of
the government subpoenaing witnesses
before the Nixon administration perhaps
they didn't have to but certainly in
private libel cases hundreds of
reporters were subpoenaed by one side or
the other and make the divulge their
sources and you said begin a discussion
that newsmen have a right and it's a
question whether Congress should certify
that right by a law but there the
Supreme Court has never found that
movement have a right not to testify if
they were witness to a crime and the
question really is is it worth elevating
newsmen to some special status by giving
them absolute
privilege which needled afters no
lawyers have and mr. Nelson says
relegate would never have been revealed
if newsmen could have been subpoenaed
well I remember that mr. Nelson I think
had it one of the single most I would
say the single most important revelation
on Medicaid as far as the public was
concerned when he published an interview
with an ex-fbi agent are prepared with
which detailed the entire litigate crime
as seen from the man who was the
intermediary between the Watergate
burglars and the conspirators hunt and
Liddy and you published this entire
interview and if you had been subpoenaed
by the way your attic is worth but let's
just say you had and you went to court
and you revealed the Bourbon was your
source I can't see that it would have
made any difference this is a little
different story though everybody didn't
fall in with this boy crying part here
was whether or not the tape of the
interview should be turned over because
they had the interview had been
conducted in incompetence and I think a
good point here is though but they were
turned over I know but the point the
arica we invested before were more than
turned over but let me tell you though I
think that's a very interesting point we
operated in an atmosphere there of an
intimidation of the government of the
news media for example
raaaah story of the LA Times and was
with me on that piece the two other new
you know in our own minds that the
government would try to get a hold of
these tape or the ball and interview we
felt sure they would so when we came
back to Washington we sent the tape to
Los Angeles and just in order to keep
the government from getting now what
happened immediately thereafter was the
Earl Jay silver there was the original
prosecutor of the Watergate case he did
tell me that you know they were going to
subpoena tation so what you do with the
tape and I said well I can't tell you
you'll have to talk to our attorney he
said well you know we're going to
subpoena those face and if we don't the
defense will well what happened was that
the defense did subpoena me and the
Justice Department and the personable
children that up important said we have
no objection to the subpoenaing of the
patient as a matter of fact we want to
see them to and that's exactly my point
if there is intimidation I think of the
media and when the Justice Department is
involved in subpoenaing of reporters but
let's say hypothetically that this that
aside from everything else this witness
Alfred Baldwin had already testified to
the grand jury had told them the entire
story he told you so even if this even
if you have been intimidated to the
point that you couldn't publish your
story still the grand jury had heard the
story and they would have brought out in
the triumph
well well that's not exactly right let's
move this way and in the process of
investigative reporting this was an
interview that went on over two nights
and the process we learned a lot of
things in that interview that did not do
in Baldwin story it was the first person
story by ball and it didn't go in
because there were things that he could
not substantiate we wanted to use these
things for investigative leaders you
know what happened we sent to Tate's to
Los Angeles because the editors asked us
to do that because we were afraid the
government was going to get them and we
never did get access to those tapes
again and we actually have access to
those tapes which and they're worth
material on there that would have been
helpful to us at that time in the
investigating Watergate I was not the
government was ill which ultimately
subpoenaed them there was it it was it
was the defense in the case whatever the
defense of subpoena but there are many
video relevant the government there who
said that they're going to subpoena and
the government said if we don't subpoena
on the defense will it was a government
who said up important said this may
range the First Amendment question but
even if it does the government has no
objection to it I'd like to connect from
the mr. Epstein said earlier about how
everyone has to testify to a crime that
he's seen and that is certainly a true
statement of law I don't think anyone
that is advocating a newsmen privilege
is really advocating except in one
particular type case which I could catch
on that there should be any exemption of
newsmen from testifying about crimes
which they say the military certainly
means absolute doesn't know it doesn't
know this is always great
it's with Lord well I know many of most
of the Justice Department subpoenas
involve two types of situations one of
which is the exact witnessing of the
crime
television news films of the shooting of
George Wallace for example and this by
the way is one reason I think the number
of government subpoenas to news men has
increased in recent years because of
television because of on-the-spot
coverage of events at which unlawful
action occurs or is charged to occur
such as demonstrations Wounded Knee and
so forth and so on these are actual
films of the the alleged the alleged
offense now either the government which
is trying to prove the offense or even
even more so the defendant who's trying
to demonstrate that he didn't do what
he's charged with it seems to me has an
overpowering right to to have that thing
shown to the grand jury and to the jury
in some cases I think the problem with
that may ABC News men were stoned in New
York City when a time came in the late
60s when they were being thought of as
being police agents an adjunct of the
New York City police force because they
were being so routinely subpoenaed that
the standard crime situation which I
think there is justification for non
testimony is the Branzburg case itself
where a reporter goes out investigates
finds out that hashish is being made in
Louisville Kentucky reports on the story
which could not have been made known to
the public absent a pledge of
confidentiality and then is subpoenaed
to testify has to leave the state
finally LC will wind up in jail and I
think the public is ill served by that
kind of the law that that is not the
typical case and I don't think that any
discussion of absolute Guzman's
privilege should center either about
solely the government's desire to get
the film or whatever it is nor should
its center solely upon the confidential
source cases which are the most
appealing from the standpoint of the
newsmen most of them do not involve
confidential sources the other the other
most common category besides news films
of events is the mailing of tapes and
and kidnap letters and such things too
newse newspapers or television news
stations or radio stations after a
kidnapping ransom notes or such-and-such
a building is going to be blown up now
on occasion these have been denied when
when the police wanted the note for the
for the purpose of trying to detect from
it where the individuals concern
happened to be located I see no reason
for the extension of a privilege in such
cases there's no no confidentiality
involved whatever and ordinarily there
isn't have you ever been killed by a
government subpoena in this received no
never when I was managing at the star we
had the the Agnew incident where there
was some effort to get our reporters
notes and that that died I haven't but I
I was wondering you know we talked about
the increase in the number of subpoenas
and efforts to legal efforts to get
material from the presses is any of that
due to the a sort of separation between
the press and the authorities and the
government that things that used to be
done cooperatively between the press and
the authorities as now as the arm's
length distance between the two has
widened and we're more conscious of the
need for separation is that one of the
factors here and you gentlemen would
know better than I wouldn't I wouldn't
think so I mean it may be a matter of
factor but I wouldn't think so I mean
for example newspaper reporters are all
cooperating all the time in cases
involving congressional investigations
encasing it involving Justice Department
of police investigations that's not
unusual for reporters to learn of some
information that has to do with a crime
and to cooperate with one law
enforcement officers that's reason I
think that the argument about whether a
reporter will testify he witnessed a
crime I don't know of any cases where
reporters not really
unless did you say in the case where
they went out and asked somebody to let
them see them make hashes so that they
could move a documentary on it in which
case nobody wouldn't own the crime
anyway you raise the case when you were
testifying for example a hypothetical
situation on the hill about the shield
law and you said that that there could
be a situation now if you had an
absolutely shield wall where a
television station could have an
interview with Patty Hearst and then the
Justice Department or other law
enforcement officials would be unable to
compel the television station to say
where they got Patty Hearst and so forth
well the point is that you would not
have a lot more about Patty Hearst at
that stage than you did before if they
didn't have the interview and had Patty
Hearst known that this television
station would tell the Justice
Department or anybody else where she was
she would have never thrown up for the
interview I just happened to all the
time the point I was making at that at
that at that point in my testimony was
was a quite different point from from
the one we had just been discussing I
think that situation could occur if you
had an absolute absolute shield law and
the main reason I think that situation
would be bad is how seriously does a
society really take the the battle
against crime if it it could allow
something like this to happen you know I
don't know where Patty Hearst is on the
FBI's most wanted list but let's let's
assume she's number one and there she is
big is life on the screen in in living
color and you know a news reporter
having having an interview with her I
just don't think a society can can take
its law enforcement efforts seriously if
it can allow something like that to
occur we've done that in 24 States where
we have privileged laws many of which
are absolute in New York for example
that that interview did occur with Patty
Hearst the New York state authorities
could not require a newsman to disclose
the source of Liang he doesn't agree
with it I am sorry you are I think I
understand that but
what I'm saying is that the country has
hasn't exactly collapsed either New York
is not precisely the best example of the
best possible you know we do have these
statutes around the country we've seen
no examples that I can cite or that have
been cited in testimony but I've read
well maybe maybe New York doesn't have
Patty Hearst I don't know I because I be
her thing would happen if Patty Hearst
would would offer it there is somebody
who would snap it up like that and I
think that something like that would
just have an enormous ly corrosive
effect upon upon we're just law
enforcement but the entire societies we
spend with me out here he on the Justice
Department know a lot more about Patty
Hearst if they saw or interviewed on
television and then they know right now
I mean they know they're very low not
necessarily they I guess they'd have a
current photograph of her that that
might be helpful my she might be
disguised yeah you're seriously
asserting that that that this would be a
help to law enforcement efforts I don't
know but I'm not saying it wouldn't be a
hundred IRA seriously assert that is up
to the public to be able to watch an
interview with Patty Hearst rather than
not and the effect of what you're saying
is that the youth is that in the future
at least you could and what if it was
Jack the Ripper would that make any
difference I mean here is Jack the
Ripper in living color
you know I out there I'm you know I'm
interviewing television I know the
police can't get this film and they
can't know where I'm being interviewed
because the laws we live under say it's
more important to watch me than it is to
catch me
Jack I don't suppose it was Adolf Hitler
20 good why mr. mr. epsteen s attack
when you said a witness a crime that you
would be for a witness being compared to
testify if he witnessed a crime what
would happen if you interviewed someone
or another reporter you respected
interviewed someone who said in the
course of the interview or inferred that
he might assassinate the president and
this came out in the interview let's say
this came out in the interview you put
it in your story and then your notes
would testify to see if they could build
a case against the person who said this
would you submit your notes would you
testify to the portions of the interview
that you didn't this was the Caldwell
case no how's that not all well okay
that's that's not the tall tall case at
all well let's not argue about this but
take his hypothetical well I'd go
directly to the authorities I don't
think I would need to if somebody told
me they were getting ready to
assassinate the President or anybody
else then what happens and see that's
the reason I say this is a fault issue I
don't think any of reporters a human
being would listen to someone threaten
say they were gonna kill someone else no
matter who it is whatever not take
action when up into the government
Martinez you know I define anybody the
gathering the public consumption game
and that's the reason I think the
unqualified shield law would not just
apply to me but it would apply to
anybody who went down the City Hall got
him from a confidential source came out
and distributed I think they ought to be
there I think we have on this side which
examples are more real and I really
think that a good part of the resolution
of these things has got to go on that
you do have a nice case I think that on
the presidential assassin in the
abstract and Jack the Ripper no but well
that there's a more real case and that
reality is really Paul Branzburg and
that reality is really a reporter who
goes down to a police station
interviews of policemen and has then
made a witness to his own interview with
the policeman and I have just been
through that with a reporter from the
New York Times and a witness to his own
interview with the policeman some of
which was confidential some of which is
not in totality it can only interfere
with the public getting the kind of
information I think it should get I
really don't think that the
assassination example which which
lawyers incidentally are confronted with
in court every time that they argue
these case there's a lot of employer
what about seeking this net was this the
prosecution in that case it what the
defense yeah one thing often is and and
if I were the defendant I wouldn't feel
so horrified about in in this instance
maybe not giving the the newsman as much
leeway as he would like it's a very hard
case when you're when you're talking
about sending a man to jail or not yeah
but I thought doesn't put any First
Amendment input on the scale at all sure
it's a hard case there are a lot of hard
cases but and and the fact that it's a
defendant in fact does impress me more
than the fact that it's law enforcement
but but to say that it doesn't seem to
me answers you know it doesn't answer it
and I concede that a court should
examine each case in which a subpoena is
sought and say is this is this really
necessary to the case is it being done
for the purpose of harassment and so
forth and so on but that is something
quite different from laying out either a
categorical shield law or even a
qualified law that gives an absolute
privilege in in in certain defined cases
which I find it very difficult to define
do you think mr. Abrams it that there is
a right to know on the part of the
public let me say that that's a phrase
that troubles me because if there's a
right to know then I suppose the public
has a right to compel the press to print
things or the judiciary may have the
right or someone may have the right to
decide what it is the public should know
I think that the First Amendment
ultimately serves the public by letting
it learn things letting it hear things
on television letting it see things that
wouldn't otherwise know there was a case
out in Indiana last year involving ABC
in which they were barred by a prior
restraint an injunction by a court for
over 200 days from doing a show
demonstrating proving that plastic cribs
burned more quickly than wooden cribs I
think the public had a right to know
precisely what ABC wanted to tell them
and that it was a most offensive
interference with the public's right and
the press is right for the courts to
intervene in that area
and to interject an injunction which
which prevented the public from knowing
what was going on about that what about
the case of the producer of hashish and
the impact that that production might
have not only on the public but children
of people watching that television
program does the society have some very
strong interest in revealing who it is
that is producing that and likely to to
introduce it into the that was not the
trust of that of that particular program
oh was it in the Branzburg case the
thrust of it was how easy it was to make
hashishin Louis VII yeah it was not to
show the people how to do it or to
encourage somebody somebody doing it
that I would then presumably distribute
it in the community that's right but the
point of though is not was not to
promote the use of it but to discourage
it that was the point of the program was
it not yeah I mean III have the same you
know that that's back to my Patty Hearst
case I I don't like that kind of that
kind of a show because it again is
telling the society look what you can do
you can go and take a picture of this
thing and somebody guess there's a lot
I'm aiming up this just open and you
know it's going to go out on the streets
but well no I know anything I know you
don't like they just show has to corrode
the the whole attitude of the society
towards whether whether it is really
opposed to come by I really think that
the Department of Justice or the courts
should refrain very strongly from
imposing what they don't like which is
what you're talking about into law it
may be and indeed it is true a lot of
things the press prints are harmful
they're destructive they've hurt people
I think we've made a decision in the
First Amendment to run that risk and not
to run the risk of having government
officials make those decisions how great
to that risk V we might move into the
issue of libel laws how is there any
right that should accrue to a private
citizen to sue the press if they step
over certain bound and accusing them of
well they have that wrong right I do I
wonder whether you agree that they
should on a my theory of
absolute privilege I'm not so sure that
I'm too much in favor of lava lols I
have to admit but they do have the right
unfortunately they do that good day I'm
in favor
you know I'm in fate almost in favor of
absolute complete fresh freedom whatever
that then it raises the issue of whether
the public would get but truth or
falsity because if even if the reporters
had the right to publish anything and to
conceal their sources so they could
concoct any deep source they wandered
it's not clear that they would be
there'll be any way of testing the truth
of what they were publishing or that in
the long run newspapers would have any
credibility well they're part of the
free enterprise system and they sink or
swim eventually but the newspapers that
succeed with the public might succeed
because they've published very plausible
lies relevant unbelievable true about
them right and that's what you would
want to see well it's not what I want to
see it's what happens in this free
market and market of the ideas and I
don't I don't think it is all bad it's
not all good but it's not all bad
there's an alternate I think yeah I
think well the alternative is got to
have strong libel laws no no have strong
libel laws Thank You Latian just this
happens in any book publishing or
academic we're in favor of stronger
libel laws and we now have oh the
library we're not in favor the library
Lords we now have her a joke when it
applies to a public figure we're almost
impossible for a public figure to
successfully sue and it's very
convenient for me as a journalist I mean
it makes things very easy but I think
that what's going to happen in the long
run is the press is going to lose its
credibility because so many things will
be published that no one will know what
to believe
well never seen as part of the effort to
help us restore that credibility by
being Yard Ombudsman but is an ombudsman
mr. C good question teller I think it is
a growing trend that's a growing trend
the press trying to please itself I
don't know if it's going to work or not
I've been in this job eight months now
and I'm not sure whether I'm doing good
or harm but the libel until the press is
ready to accept its responsibilities a
little better than I think it has
does generally I think probably the
libel laws at least protecting the
rights of the private citizen who
doesn't by running for office or by
taking public office expose himself I
think that's the minimum we should have
right now I can't quite see that the
press is ready to remove all restraints
and rely totally on the marketplace and
the ultimate triumph of good over evil -
to solve the problem I my the area I'm
concerned with is is fairness and
accuracy and balance that doesn't really
come under the libel laws the libel laws
sort of the last resort for the as you
say the the public figure really doesn't
have much access to them anymore well
your your the access I'm the access now
or to the extent that that the extent
that a corrective piece or a discussion
piece ever catches up with the original
error let me try to get back to that
toward the image to see because I think
it's important what might be done by the
press itself to ensure responsibility do
you see any other restrictions for
instance in the name of national
security on the right of the pressed of
print material that comes into their
hands
I don't we I'm sure you could concoct a
case where national security or the
security of certain individuals required
restraint in public asset publishing a
story at least for a short time but
generally speaking the claims to
national security I think should be very
harshly examined by the editors by the
press my position is that the President
does have absolute privilege under the
First Amendment that editors being
privileged to do what to report whatever
it gets a hold of that the courts in
other words have no role in trying to
restrict in correction and printing it
even if it were to involve a what
reasonable man's definition would be a
most grossly irresponsible act may
jeopardize the lives of some people
still the courts would have no right to
move in well that's hard to say I mean
philosophically I believe that I because
I believe that about our practice in
practice I think first of all I think
they would move man I don't think I
think it's kind of a look it's not very
hard to get the press not to run us
that's right it's too easy it's a night
affair it's very easy to get to craft
not to run a story William Colby went
around and got the Los Angeles Times and
The New York Times in the Washington
Post Newsweek and time and NBC and CBS
and ABC and Public Broadcasting and I
don't know who else not to run the globe
our exploratory on grounds of national
security
now the story Iran and nobody's been
able to tell anyone where national
security was really involved look at the
picture of this a official running
around town trying to stop this thing
dribbling little bits of information as
he went because in each each
conversation he in order to to convince
the the parties not to publish he gave
them a little more information it was
really ridiculous do you think that a
published public interest was served
actually I thought the I read the story
in in Los Angeles Times did they publish
the story before the times - two weeks
before the wrong motion right there was
already published but it's - that up I
don't see the public interest that was
served by publishing that the CIA was
perfectly legitimately retrieving a
Russian submarine from international
waters it's the only legitimate
operation I've ever heard satisfy your
it's done alright let me ask you
something Gilda the ship out in the
middle of the ocean
operated by Howard Hughes there's always
was an upright well alright it was home
by Howard Hughes it was a Howard Hughes
operation if the Howard Hughes CIA
operation sure it was the CIA itself the
CIA evolved it was one of our billion
dollars of the plenty of it in any event
you see nothing wrong with a private
contractor album out on the sleeve of
covering a Russian submarine and with
the with the involvement of Howard
Hughes has always been on sort of the
fringes of the Cheney government
operations you see nothing wrong with
that you don't think the American people
are entitled know about wait a moment
the up the retrieval of the submarine
was done by Howard Hughes built the ship
but then it was taken over by another
company
yeah which is also a Howard Hughes
operation well in any case I think it
was also you know two ways working with
nobody else will say no I don't see
anything wrong I think it's a great job
if indeed it happened the way they said
work story is that the key to what the
reason not to publish it is very clear
is it stopped them from retrieving the
rest of the submarine that's the reason
not to publish it and it that's what
they say destroyed the expenditure do
you think that the Russians didn't know
that this ship was out there I mean it's
right said they assumed but this is the
cleaning issue who is to be the arbiter
of what the prayer of what the you
wouldn't be the arbiter of whether
something is of interest to national
security whether the press would somehow
know what the Russians listen what the
right listen no I don't want to be the
obvious one security argument was used
to cover up Watergate to cover up the
Ellsberg burger with all of the things
that came out after Watergate national
security was stamped on almost every one
of course in other words you want to be
the arbiter of whether some operation is
national security or not let's just get
this very clear let's face it that by
your education and your knowledge of the
world that you are not just me the
person generally well I just can't take
that what do you want to be alternative
minute mr. Epstein the alternative is
allowing the Department of Justice and
the court system that other branch of
government to make those same decisions
as to what the press can print
and I think that that has very
considerable risks which were well
recognized in the First Amendment itself
depending on papers of course is a good
example of that God knows we heard
enough about national security in that
case about documents which were
historically without another case but
was another day indeed of where the
press cooperated with the government
wasn't the new tomorrow what do you mean
by the press I asked before who is a
newsman they talked about the press
cooperating we got the picture everybody
would know well and they go there's one
big on paper out by the court some cases
have been so that the court ordered some
cases that have come before the court
have involved reporters from from an SDS
underground newspaper and and do these
people have any less claim to being
reporters no all right then then you say
it's it's one thing if a a spy gets
information and disseminates it but it's
quite something else if he's working on
the staff at the Daily Worker is that is
that the distinction you you draw if
it's the Daily Worker it may be
espionage and if it's espionage it
should be liable to criminal prosecution
but if it's oh you newsgathering yes if
it but I think there is a distinction I
don't think it's a hard distinct I don't
want to be on the other side in court
having a demonstration well I would hope
that you would recognize that
distinction between The Daily Worker and
and other newspapers which gather news
for the purpose of reporting news to the
public you surely can't distinguish
between one newspaper and another you
all right over some principle as to well
it's not wired well look you know you
know if a reporter for The Daily Worker
is involved in espionage work the
results of that are not going to show up
in the Daily Worker if you have to
assume that to have a free press and
I've convinced that the system wouldn't
work without it there's a price now
perhaps it would have been better the
CIA might have been able to go back I've
gotten the code machine if such there
exists if we hadn't printed a the Glomar
story but that was a price for freezes
so what did we gain for that price other
than one day I buy this I don't know
anything either we don't even know that
we got anything all we know is what the
CIA told that's all and we do know they
don't always tell us about them I have
no way of knowing what a code machine is
no less how it would be valuable to
figuring out some Soviet codes are not
figuring on I agree with you I'm
absolutely ignorant in this fear but
then how can we be the arbiters of
whether something is legitimate national
security or not that's the dilemma as I
see it that no one has to know that
maybe the press ought to give in a
credible government sometimes believe it
yes and I have no objection to call be
going around Washington trying to
persuade obviously a lot of arrests not
to make the decision about whether to
believe obviously a lot of editors did
believing because they didn't run the
story until finally Jack Anderson broke
it on radio one night so obviously a lot
of editors and a lot of television news
executives did believe mr. Kolbo I think
it's this analysis of the global thing
is hey as to the possible harm it could
could could have done is is really not
as not as profound as it ought to be
what action the Russians can take if
they already know it may be quite
different from what actions the Russians
can take and feel obliged to take if
they already know it and the whole world
knows that they know it it's obvious
that freedom of the press means
different things to different people
sometimes even the courts have trouble
interpreting this basic constitutional
protection especially when there's a
conflict among the people's right to
know protection of individual rights and
the safety of the Republic now to
challenge our speakers on freedom of the
press let's go to our experts in the
audience without any more introduction
than that I would like to call on
somebody from the audience you might
have a question yes sir I'm a hard penny
one from Georgetown University back in
June the Los Angeles Times printed a
story by George MacArthur about the
heavy bombing of South Vietnam on the
last days of the war and then has
perceived wrote an excellent
for commentary on it a little later and
then last week and the 25th the Los
Angeles Times wrote a retraction of it
indeed George MacArthur himself wrote
the retraction and the post on the
following day 20-day note on the
retraction the post including the note
said that it was clear that the White
House and the Pentagon did not have any
any responsibility for any significant
moment but the post did not include was
included in the Los Angeles Times which
was that all the effort made by the
reporter in Washington could find no
evidence of any significant bombing in
fact to have been ordered by anyone
furthermore which leaves still some
questions what how far did the Los
Angeles Times or should the Los Angeles
Times go in protecting something with
you more or less laughingly referred to
as American reputation or American face
and that is involved in this is it
enough to simply absolve the president
is it enough to simply say that yes we
have now said there was not significant
bombing which still leaves implied that
there was some kind of bombing a fact
which is not yet demonstrated all of
this from one of these wonderful sources
which we are to protect I'd be glad to
hear mr. Skelly on on anything about
whether he believes this is adequate
their protection of national security
well the third judgments appear to be
good or either the others on what is a
defense of such action
I don't want to answer it I guess for
the reason that I really sort of jump
off the boat as far as the proper role
of government is concerned when it when
it comes to correcting the the news
media being sure that what they're
reporting they're reporting accurately
incorrectly that's that's none of my
business I don't think it's any of any
of the government's business that's
something quite different what we were
talking about earlier was just a simple
question of can the government obtain
information it needs that is that is
necessary for the administration of
justice and can the government in some
situations at least prevent the
dissemination of information that would
be detrimental to the to vital national
interests those two questions are quite
different from the the problem of if you
want to call it irresponsibility of the
press I think we've made a decision
under the First Amendment that they can
be as irresponsible in what they choose
to say as as as they wish and that the
corrective is to is the voices of those
that are responsible and can correct
them and to some to some extent the
libel laws I suppose well I would agree
with mr. Scalia that there's not a
something for the government to take any
action home or anyone else other than
the newspaper itself now the government
did take action in that the government
not only denied it that pursuit is
denial as a matter of fact I happen to
run into Ron Nelson the president's
press secretary at a bar you know and
the and the evening before the
retraction came out he was not just a
day before but some time before and
Nessen told me at the time he said you
had this story and he said we recalled
in and we told the Los Angeles Times
that the White House unequivocally
denied that the bombing had taken place
and he said yet you ran the story and
down in the story you ran the denial
parenthetically he said we think that's
wrong and I said well I don't know any
more about it than what you just told me
and what I've seen in the paper and
don't have more than substantiated than
that I think you're right I think it is
wrong and he said he was going to write
to the editor which I'm sure he did now
Charles Siva did write a an editorial
column on it as young businessman for
the Washington Post in which he said the
the LA Times had never been able to
substantiate his original story bill
Thomas the editor of the paper took it
very seriously he looked into it he
George MacArthur who wrote the story and
was been our Saigon Bureau came back to
the United States he spent two or three
weeks trying to prove whether the
information was wrong or whether it had
been right and the government denial was
was wrong he could never really get any
substantiation for it and he admitted it
and he wrote the story but I think the
point is and Bill Thomas said this in
the end the article that MacArthur wrote
Gil Thomas said that that the Los
Angeles Times was wrong it should not
have run the story because it got an
unequivocal - now that he should have
gone back to MacArthur and this is this
is not really an excuse but it's what
happened the communication never got
back to the MacArthur that there was an
absolute unequivocal denial and the
story ran with the denial the old Thomas
says the paper should have never run it
we ran a page one correction as Charles
Eames said probably the longest
retraction in the history of journalism
the Washington Post ran on page one in
York Times picked it up and ran it and I
think we should have run it I don't know
what else you can do beyond that but I
think it's a good reflection of what
newspapers are addressing themselves to
now and a matter of responsibility only
things we've got an ombudsman now for
example or at least a media critic by
the name of David Shaw he does the same
sort of criticism in a sense of Charles
he does and frequently writes his for
everyone on page one and he has
criticized the Los Angeles Times as well
as other parts of the news media when
he's found that they've been in error
but I don't know what else we could do
other the other than corrected I mean
you can't
I suppose if a man got too far out and
was involved in the story you might run
the risk of his job I'm sure that that
whoever was on the desk and who didn't
get the message back to MacArthur or
something he's probably heard from the
editor about it I don't
you can do though as you see I like to
call it or not because I think that that
whole episode raises a couple of points
to go far beyond the story first of all
one of the main reasons I wrote the
column was not because I knew whether
the story was right or wrong because I
didn't at that time but I had a feeling
that neither the postman at the time was
ever going to tell us whether it was
right or wrong I think the press has
been very reluctant to clean up its own
messes and both the post in The Times
led with that story at Sunday morning
and making a charge sticking a couple of
parenthetical denials in it and I knew
that was going to just die there unless
somebody gave him a push well you say
you don't know what the press to do
about publishing something that might be
a falsehood and I think there's a very
simple thing the press could do and it
doesn't involve the government at all
the journalist could simply publish his
source in this case if the McArthur had
published who had told him that the
United States had bombed Vietnam on that
day that's to us would be quickly
discredited let me give you an example
there was a charge made that Alex
Butterfield was a CIA agent in the White
House the New York Times to its credit
if it didn't name its source it
intimated so strongly that its source
was this man Fletcher Prouty was
everything yeah that very quickly people
from zeroed in on him and it became
clear that he named his source then as E
Howard hunt and very quickly a Howard
hunt then denied that that he knew
anything at all about brother field and
and Butterfield was cleared without a
major thorn I mean either would have no
sources that we identified at least well
but is it better that the government
have the truth who's the client of
newspapers is it the public or is it
there's so much if you're trying to
protect the source or the reporter sure
it's better for the reporter he never
names is so as for what about the ten
million readers of the Los Angeles Times
who read that the farmer was wrong
whenever they know they might not they
might not have read the same people read
the paper on one day might not have read
it on another day also the New York the
Los Angeles Times denial wasn't
unequivocal it said there no significant
bombing we were able to establish it
becomes much more confusing let me
mr. Nelson there what effect you you
indicate that is responsibility to act
responsibly should primarily be left to
the press and not exclusively left for
the press what effect do you think the
competition for news has on the exercise
of this responsibility well I think it
has I think it has a tremendous effect
and not only that I think that the whole
diversification of the media has a
tremendous effect I mean if we go out to
do for a negative
well it's positive I don't think any
question about that I mean if we go away
out on the level on something as we did
on the Vietnam gone you know we're going
to get caught short on it you've got all
the news magazines you've got the
network's you've got the large
newspapers you've got all the wire
services APU P the Supplemental news
services and if you really make a
substantial error on a matter of some
importance you're going to be did you
see a public employment is going to know
about it and and it's gonna know about
it beyond on mr. seeds work because
other publications will find out about
it
and you can't retain yourself how often
do other publications point out the air
I made on matters of substance I think
they do it frequently they may not say
that this was an error but they print
the story as it really happened but you
know to what extent do you think the
competition that occurs forces you to
come out with stories before you're able
to completely verify their actors well I
think it happens sometimes and I think
it's regrettable I don't think it
happens very often I mean I can remember
a few very bad examples I can remember
three
the Eagleman matter involving Jack
Anderson which I thought was bad which
he later admitted was bad but how many
instances can you think I'm on a really
major matter for a newspaper or radio or
television came out with something of
real importance that was wrong the
public we're trying to be first they do
it when they do it unexcusable sure let
me give the Agnew case solving the vice
president the United States the
competition among the press was fierce
in that case they were all over the
Justice Department halls and the US
Attorney's office in Baltimore plus the
vice president's office himself trying
to get information on an ongoing
investigation for which there was no
cover-up much many of the story although
all of the happening however in the
aftermath of Watergate things yeah I'm
not saying here was it was an
understandable that doesn't make it
justifiable I'm not really into many of
the stories were published were full of
inaccuracies don't you think the
Butterfield Prouty incident was based on
comfort air might have not happened if
they had if the NBC and CBS hadn't been
so competitive yeah I think it's
possible and I think you know there are
there are cases but I don't think there
are that many major cases where you find
this and what it does happen is
absolutely inexcusable I don't think
there's any way to to say that
newspapers or television are right ever
when they try to be first when they're
wrong
and I don't think that's the trend
either I think the trend is in the
opposite direction I know it's a trend
for example on the Los Angeles Times and
has been for a long time we've been told
for example the Washington bureau look
and I've had particular cases where I
would be on a story and saying the New
York Times is here the Washington Post
is here and and this was in the past few
years and the editor on the edges will
just hold on don't get the story now I
get it
be sure you get it all be sure it's
absolutely right we don't care if
they're first that everybody wants to be
part you know there's no question about
that but I don't think that's the trend
in general
in this country I think the trend is me
right up first don't get it right get it
read there's no longer screams in the
city
Cairo's I think that's right mr.
Ruckelshaus is not suggesting I take
that we'd be better off we had only one
newspaper there I'm not but I think that
it often is missed on the part of the
public that the competition for news
particularly here in Washington it's
very strong and that this competition
itself has a way of creating its own
momentum for a story to be published
before there is adequate opportunity to
verify having been involved in the
middle of this Eggman investigation I
thought that was a prime example of
where the New York Times would
editorialize about the Justice
Department leaking information which we
were unable to find and the newspaper up
and as though this was awful why don't
they protect this poor man's right and
then they unleash a horde of reporters
in that same Department trying to get a
certain Olympian wasn't that the
Washington Post no that was a good don't
you agree though that that that there
have been unusual event in Washington in
the past few years I would relegate and
the fact that you know the resistance of
government to give out information of
legitimate public interest information
it should have been given out it took 18
months to find out it was on the White
House payroll during the Nixon
administration I mean just mattered you
could go down
yes I think that we are running out of
time and again in closing if I would
like to indicate to my appreciation in
the end of the panel for the audience's
participation and recognize that while
we've all joined here together and by no
means will we leave in complete
agreement one of the principles that has
been stood up for a year with such great
articulation by the defenders of the
press I believe is precisely the reason
we're able to meet like this as free men
and women and discuss as freely as
possible with little chance of any
interference issues as important as
freedom of the press and it's in the
future of this society so again on on
behalf of the panel let me thank all of
you for your participation and thank the
members of the panel for being here
[Music]
this roundtable discussion has brought
you the ideas of five experts who have
differing views on the many
interpretations of freedom of the press
it's the aim of the American Enterprise
Institute to illuminate issues of the
day by presenting many such views in the
hope that by so doing those in positions
of decision-making will benefit from
such a free exchange of informed and
enlightened opinion I'm Peter hackus in
Washington public policy forums is
created and supplied to this nation as a
public service by the American
Enterprise Institute Washington DC
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]